ya
Ben çocukken Türkan Şoray'ı Annem
olduğunu sanıyorsun Hayal etmiyordum
istemiyordum Hani aldıktan sonra benim
annem olsun demiyorum Sadece o benim
annem de buna inanıyorum biliyorum
bilmek ne kadar tehlikeli birşey değil
mi bildikçe insanı birisi başka bir
şeyler gördükçe öğrendikçe daha da
birisi geliyor sonuçlar değişiyor Ee ben
de kendi hikayemi anlatayım Nasıl
sonuçlarını değiştiğine bilmenin Nasıl
sihirli Bazen çok acıtıcı bazen
hırpalayıcı ama Deniz değiştirici ve
dönüştürücü olduğunu veya ben keşfedelim
o Türkan Şoray'ın Annem olduğunu
sanıyorum ve biz Ben Manisa Akhisar'da
doğdu orada büyüdüm Çıkmaz bir sokakta
oturuyoruz o zaman ki küçük bende de o
Sokak böyle kilometreleri gibi Ama
bugünden bakınca o Sokak sanki
50 metre Belki 100 metre ve ben her gün
sokağın başına gidip oturuyorum ve
Türkan Şoray'ın gelip beni almasını
bekliyorum
Hani o filmlerdeki açık güzel arabalar
var ya o arabalarla gelip Annem beni
alacak neden Bu fikre Kapıldım ve Çünkü
evlatlık olduğunu biliyorsunuz Ben
evlatlık büyüdüm Annemle babam ayrılınca
beni başka bir aile vermişler bunu çok
küçük yaşta öğrendim Benim bildiğimi
benden başka hiç kimse bilmiyordu ve o
gerçeğin değişmemesi için değil mi hiç
kimseye söylemiyorum
bakanımız vardı bir tane
hacı amca hacı amca bana herhalde O da
beni gülüyordu Her gördüğün Hoş geldin
Türkan Şoray nasılsın Türkan Şoray diye
bizi bugün diyordu Oh bak bilmediği hali
onu söylemediğim Anne benim Türkan
Şoray'ı kız olduğumu anlıyor Çünkü
Türkan Şoray bana diye düşünüyordum
Benim hayallerim ne zaman sona erdi
biliyor musunuz Füruzan diye bir
edebiyatçı var çok iyi bir tanımlaması
var diyor ki Beyhude de çok istekli
beklemeler
O benim de işte öyle Beyhude çok samimi
çok istekli o sokakbaşı Türkan Şoray'ın
beni gelip almasını beklemelerin şöyle
sona erdi bir gün gerçek biyolojik annem
okula geldi beni görmeye bizim bütün
dünyam yıkıldı Çünkü o Türkan Şoray
değildi ve gerçekten Sabah kalktım o
zamanlar televizyonda küçük elbisesi
vardır gençler bilmez ama bilen biri
küçük evde değil oraya benzetiyorlar the
ben de Şey yapıyordum İyi geceler
babacığım İyi geceler Bütün İyi geceler
kardeşim öyle uyudum Sabah da annemi
öperek okula gidiyordum yine Annem
öperek okula gittim okula gittiğim anda
dediler ki annen gelmiş Nasıl ya anneme
de ya ona verdiğin cevap bir çare Nasıl
ya benim annem Türkan Şoray niye beni
gelip Sokağın başından almadı Niye
buraya geldi kadın bana koşarken Feryad
ediyorsun Yavrum u o yavrum o yavrum
yavrumun içinde bugünkü Aslında bakınca
Özlem vardığı düşmanlık vardı
kavuşmak istediği vardı ama ben de bana
sorarsanız benim kalbim küçük çok
Hayır değil mi
O benim hayallerim orada bitti ne zaman
biliyor musunuz yine oradan kaçtım evin
önüne geldim beni bir tane annem hadi
sabah ve ayrıldım annemin yanına kapıyı
çaldım Annem çıktı anne dedim gerçekten
çok çıkmasını istiyorum Oradan gitmek
istemiyorum çok tatlı insanlarda nur
içinde yatsınlar Onların ikisi de
cennete gittikleri düşünüyorum beni çok
şefkatle sevgiyle büyütüyor ama işte
yani sonuçta böyle
Sonra anneme Dedim ki anne bir tane
kadın çocuğunu kaybetmiş beni ona
benzetmiş ve bağırarak bana doğru
koşuyordu ben de kaçtım
mi Evet yalan söyledim biliyordum
gerçeği ama orada annenin sırtındaki
hedefini annemin korkusu annem eyvah
dedim eyvah gerçek bu ilkokula
gidiyordum ve gelecek Annem de bunu
onayladı Evet o kadar benim annem de
Türkan Şoray Benim annem değildi o zaman
ne yapacaktım her şeyi açacak bir beni
olmayacak zaten hiç istemiyorum o kadar
çok kolaydı bu kadar çok dua ettim ki
neyse bir şekilde o gün örtbas ettiler
ve ben hiçbir şey yokmuş gibi hayatımıza
tekrar devam ettik hiçbir şey yokmuş
gibi sonra bizim Ben ilkokulda şeye
gittim gidiyorum bilmiyorum yine
hatırlayanlar güzel cumartesi günleri
okula gidiyorduk bize ve oradan bizi
kadınlar makinesini götürüyorlar kadına
makinesine götürdüklerini de kadınlar
matinesinde bölü arka ve üç tane Film
seyrediyoruz Mora böyle evlatlık yüreği
anne filmleri çok fazla Evet ve
sanatın tılsımlı ev oradaki evlatlık
çocuklar diğer çocuklardan daha
yetenekli daha güzel daha akıllı
verenler kötü ama Elazığ büyüyen
çocuklar çok tatlı Ben aklımda dedim ki
A
Ama ben de çok güzel O zaman ben de çok
yetenekliyim Çünkü ben de evlatlığım
işte o beni kurtardı O benim yaşama
bağladı ve Ben her sabah hala bugün 58
yaşındayım her sabah şöyle uyanıyorum Oh
be
yaşıyorum ölmedim ve bugün daha çok şey
yapabilirim bunun Yalnız bu kadar değil
ya bizimde gibi değil Bak Söylediğim
kadar bile değil sonra başka bir dedenin
daha buldum her sabah mutlu uyanmanın
nedenini buldum Hani Türk filmleri Evet
ama bir neden daha bulduk sonra Hayat
Devam Ediyor ikinci hayatımı Sarsıcı
bilgi
adımın ne olduğunu bilmiyor musun
meğerse Çünkü
babam biyolojik Babam her hafta beni
görmeye geliyordu ben onu babam olduğunu
yine Biliyordum yine benden başka hiç
kimse benim bildiğimi bilmiyordum
herhalde beni görmeye geliyordu çok
yakışıklı bir adamdı ve benim saçlarımı
tarama yok Ben de kendim Çünkü
kalıyordum Hatta Yani benim babam var Bu
karar filan öyle şeyler yapıyordum
Adamcağız da ama yine de ısrarla her
hafta beni görmeye geliyordu sonra
ortaokula giderken ben bir gün beni
büyüten babam okula geldi ve bana dedi
ki
bu Mustafa amcan ördüm yani biyolojik
babam 35 yaşında trafik kazasında öldü
ve beni aldığı cenazeye götürdü ev dedim
ki Ama senin arkadaşın ben de cenazeye
gidiyorum ve için yine çok korkuyorum
diyorum ki aynı yine gerçek ortaya
çıkacağım ama
bu kurtulamadım bundan beni alıp cenaze
evine götürdüler küçük yerlerde
bilirsiniz yaşadınız mı bilmiyorum
keşfettiniz mi it fark ettiniz mi
böyle genç çözümler bir sıra gecede
dönüşür ama sadece kadar olaylar büyür
herkes daha çok ağlar gibi çözümü
değiştir daha acıdır işte babam 35
yaşında trafik kazasında ölmüştü
biyolojik Babam ve belli büyüten Babam
beni cenazeye götürdü Ve ben o gün hiç
defa akrabalarımla karşılaştım bir ev
dolusu bir kasabada Büyüdüm Ben Manisa
Akhisar'da 11 bu
bahçenin içinde bir sürü insan komşular
akrabalar bir tane sandalye koydular
bile oturttular gelemem türküden öptü
Hani ondan bize kalan gibi ve aklınız
neredeydi bu çocuk başkasının evine
gidince ben Neredeydiniz e akrabalar
demek istiyorum içinden ortaokula
gidiyorum bilmişim de biraz
diyemedim demedim dik durdum Big habire
etkilemiyor gibi durdum ama o kadar çok
etkiledi ki o kadar Ondan sonra uzun
süre geceler iç öyle kabuslar gördüm
da seslenmek istiyorum sesin çıkmıyor
Yürümek istiyorum ayaklarım yere
yapışıyor ve kalkmıyor yerinden bu
kabuslar uzun süre benimle beraber devam
etti ama sabahlar Mutlu uyanıyordum
Çünkü
şuursuz bir mutluluk var bende ben
şuursuz mutluluk birazdan duruyorum bunu
Çünkü ben
Ben her sabah öyle uyanıyorum nedenle
birazdan anlatacağım sonra
ve babamın cenazesinden sonra anne
tarafı mahkeme açtı beni almak için Çok
korkuyorum gitmek istemiyorum
var ama babamdan korktukları için işte
bir gün beni okula görmeye gelmek
dışında bir daha hiç görmemişim
mahkemeye verdiler velayet davası babam
ölünce ve ben orada öğrendim ki bu aile
beni aldıklarında çok gençler miş yasal
olarak evrak edememişler sonra kendi
çocukları olmuş yine evde dilemişler ama
bana bir isim koymuşlar kendi soy
isimlerini vermişler ama öyle bir yok
feodal ilişkiler ve Okullardaki
liselerde de o yazıyordu
mahkemede adımı ve soyadım öğrendim
Ondan sonra uzun süre yine liseyi
bitirip üniversiteye gidince kadar tabii
eski adım soyadım kullandım Çok ortalığa
yayılmadı hallettiler hakim Amca dedim
ki hakim amca ben ne olur gitmek
istemiyorum Ben gitmek istemiyorum beni
bırakmış bir kadının yanına gitmek ya
ben bu Annemi babamı kardeşlerimi bu
Evimi çok seviyorum Ne olur Ne olur bir
göndermeyin dedim O da beni göndermedi
ne yaptı biliyor musunuz su hukuk
hakimliği benim velayetini takip etti ve
ben eski evinde kaldım 18 yaşına kadar
18 yaşına kadar orada kaldım Ve böylece
yine götürmüştüm yine yapmıştım
da
Okumayı da çok sevdim Sabahları mutlu
uyanmayı da Evet Ee ben madem
bu kadar mutlu uyanıyorum Bu kadar
hayatının içinde edici hırpalayıcı
şeyler var tabi Bugün biz burada bilinen
ötesini konuştuğumuz için hayatımdaki
daha acıtır almadık şeyleri anlatmak
anlatmayı seçtim onları size Hayal
gücünüze bırakıyorum onlarla beraber Ben
bütün bu neden bu kadar mutluyum diye
perişanlık yaşıyorum
sorgulamaya başladım büyümüşüz geçti
doğmuşum Hatta o zaman
tiyatroya gidiyorum gittim Neden ben
orada
Hah
kullanmıyorum Neden hemen olayı
toparlıyorum Neden adını sonra öğrenmeme
rağmen yine sabah mutlu uyanıyorum beni
travmatik ortaya koydular hırpaladı lar
yine sabah mutlu uyanıyorum neden neden
Sen beni alet nedenle ulaştım
bu biyoloji kalemliği
beni büyüten annem bende Büyüdükçe artık
bu konuları konuşma ile geldiğimizde
bana anlattı Benim Babam
ya Kamil Koç ya da ki Koç Ay Neyse
bunları söylemem gerekiyordu herhalde
bekle ama neyse
abone ol
o silah mi bitti diye baktım benim babam
otobüs şoförünü annemle ayrıldıklarında
evlenmeleri ayrılmaları da ayrı problem
ayrıldıklarında
mahkeme velayetini anneme vermiş Annem
de
bir bayram günü küçük yerlerde yine
böyle bayramlarda pazarlar mesire
yerleri eğlenceler kurulur oralarda
babam gidip kucağından alıp Kaçırmış ama
bu arada babam 23 yaşında Askerden yeni
gelmiş Kendisi de annesiz büyümüş
kardeşlerinin arasında orta bir yerde bu
sonra beni alıp
ba ba kalmayınca uzun bir süre işte bir
de genç yaşta karısını boşayan çocuğunu
çocuğuyla falan bir erkeğin eline küçük
yerlerde yine Kimse gelip çocuğuna
bakmaz Ben çocuğun
E ne yapayım dedim şimdi herhalde aldı
ve sonra
bir süre
ama oradaki azınlıklardan birilerine
baktırıyor olmuyor
sonra hafta sonları bile kamyonu var
farkında yük taşıyor ek iş olarak beni
kamyonun içinde taşıyor olmuyor en
sonunda şöyle bir çare buluyor
eskiden kaybolanlar vardı Böyle
Demirayak alabilirsiniz
36 ay 8 ay arası bir bebek beni o
Karyolanın de bir ayağına bağlıyor
şu ve yola gidiyor
bu işte Akhisar'dan İzmir'e İzmir'den
İstanbul'a İstanbul'dan İzmir'e
İzmir'den Akhisar'a o kadar uzun sürede
bu çocuk tek başına kalıyor yani ben ama
Biliyoruz şimdi öyle Mucizeler var
depremde kaç saat falan çocuklar var
Evet o kadar uzun süre kalınca
Bu bir kulağım Sağır
ve ateşin üstüne olduysa bilmiyorum Bir
böbreğim böbreğim daha küçük herhalde
susuzlukta ama yazmıyorum nedeni buldum
Ben diyorum ki
içinden ve artık dışında sizde duy diye
o küçücük
çaresiz
konuşamayan bağlı yürüyemeyen çocuk
Bu bir şey yapamazdı küçük bir hata
arıyorsa belli tutmuyordu bağlıydı ama
ben ben
[Müzik]
bu Elim tutuyor aklım ediyor cafeem
ağzında lafı Bahar yapamayacağım Ne var
ki benim Hayatı seviyorum orada onda
ölmediysem Demek ki yapacağım çok şey
var benim o yüzden ben yine hala o
çocuğa Çok sıkılıyorum Bazen onun adına
kendimi gezmeye götürüyorum geliyorum
ben seni seviyorum diyorum yani Bak
diyorum Dünya böyle diyorum İyi ki
görmedin sen diyorum İyi ki tutunduğum
ilki zorlandım He ki ben seni senden
büyüdüm diyorum ve ben Böylece yine
mutlu yanmaya devam ediyoruz ve ben
hayatı çok seviyorum Tabii ki
yıkılmaları mı olmuyor bu travmaların
olmuyor mu Üzülme lerimi olmuyorum Ama
bir gün sürüyor hemen çocuk beni ayağa
kaldırıyor işte
her şey bildiğimiz gibi göründüğü gibi
değil size tavsiye verecek değilim
Sadece bu hikaye belki size
ne yapılır öyle değil midir gider tahlil
yaptırırız referanslar alırız ne işe
yaradı ne olduğumuzu İşte bunlar size
referans oluyor bir anlatıyorum ben
bilmeyi çok seviyoruz çok meraklı bir
çocuğum çocuktum hala yavru çocuk o
çocukla beraber yaşıyoruz ama bir gün
bana dediler ki bunu böyle bunu orada
anlatıyorsun bunları böyle söylüyorsun
geceler olmuyor mu senin canını
acıtmıyor mu Hayır canım acıtmıyor hayır
seviyorum
bu öyle bir hikaye olduğu için
seviniyorum beni ben onun gücü dediği
için seviyorum
hayatım bana sunduklarını değil de
bunların içindeki mucizeyi aradığım için
seviniyorum öyle bir de öyle bir sonsuz
bilgi iyileştirecek bir He tedavi edici
bilgi çarpıcı bilgi acıtıcı ama Ben
bilmekten korkmuyorum bilmek istiyorum
Çünkü hayat gibi nasıl doğuyoruz
büyüyoruz her gün yeni bir benle
uyanıyoruz her gün her gün her gün
Einstein hastalık tanımı var
biliyorsunuz her gün aynı şeyleri
yaparsanız ve aynı sonuçları ve farklı
sonuçlar beklerseniz aptalsınız diyor
işte onun için ben her uyandığım günde
yeni bir şey öğrenmek yeni bir mucizeyi
keşfetmek yeni bir mucize yaratmak
sevdasıyla yaşıyoruz Bu da benim için
çok kıymetli gerçekten ve sevgiler
[Alkış]